6 cuadrados unitarios tienen cada uno
dos tercios de su área coloreada y lo
puedes ver aquí
si tienes por aquí un entero uno de
estos cuadrados observa que este
cuadrado está dividido en tres partes
aquí tengo un tercio dos tercios tres
tercios y solamente dos de los tres
tercios están coloreados así que si ves
aquí tengo uno dos tres cuatro cinco
seis cuadrados unitarios y cada uno
obtiene dos tercios de su área coloreada
por lo tanto si observas de aquí hasta
acá tengo seis veces dos tercios del
área coloreada es decir 6 por 2
y me dicen cuál es el área total
coloreada bueno pues es buen momento
para que te invite a que pausa el vídeo
e intente resolver esto por tu cuenta
bueno pues recuerda lo siguiente cada
una de estas barras que tengo aquí cada
una de éstas representan un tercio
porque si tengo un entero dividido en
tres partes eso quiere decir que una de
estas partes va a representar un tercio
así que en esta ocasión estoy tomándome
un tercio ahora bien me puedo preguntar
cuántos tercios tengo coloreados así que
vamos a contarlos y para eso
déjenme usar este color tengo uno de
ellos dos de ellos tres de ellos cuatro
de ellos cinco de ellos
73 y 28 329 tercios 10 311 tercios y 12
tercios por lo tanto podemos decir que
tenemos dos tercios sombreados y ahora
sí si me preguntan cuál es el área total
coloreada puedo decir que son 12 12
tercios que por cierto esto es lo mismo
que cuatro unidades cuadradas enteras
coloreadas 2 entre 3 es 4
bien esto estuvo muy sencillo así que
qué te parece si hacemos otro ejemplo y
para eso voy a quitar este de aquí y
vamos a poner el siguiente que va a ser
este de acá
cuánto es dos tercios de 15 y bueno aquí
nos dan una pista si observas tenemos
aquí 15 triángulos 5 aquí 5 aquí y 5
aquí y por algo debe de ser una pista
porque se observa se están dividiendo
estos 15 triángulos entre
es partes iguales aquí tengo una de
ellas aquí tengo otra de ellas y por acá
tengo otra de ellas son tres grupos
iguales y cada uno de estos grupos
tienen cinco triángulos observa aquí
tengo uno de estos grupos dos de estos
grupos y tres de estos grupos por lo
tanto si lo piensas de esta manera
puedes ver que uno de estos grupos este
por ejemplo de aquí es lo mismo que un
tercio de 15 triángulos aquí tengo un
tercio de estos 15 triángulos pero ojo
no nos preguntan por un tercio de 15
triángulos nos preguntan por dos tercios
dos tercios de 15 así que sí aquí ya
tenemos un tercio de 15 bueno pues me
voy a tomar otro de ellos este es otro
tercio
otro tercio de 15 y ahora sí si me tomo
a estos dos juntos déjenme atraparlos si
me tomo
todos juntos observa que aquí ya tengo
dos tercios de 15 así que habrá que ver
cuántos triángulos tenemos y dice uno
dos tres cuatro cinco seis siete ocho
nueve diez tengo diez triángulos
entonces cuánto es dos tercios de quince
bueno pues es diez muy bien así que
vamos a hacer uno más y para eso voy a
quitar este de aquí y vamos a traer al
siguiente dice cuánto es tres cuartos de
dos y nos dan esta pista aquí tengo dos
enteros completos te das cuenta y cada
uno de estos enteros está dividido en
dos así que si lo piensas de esta manera
aquí tengo un médium aquí tengo otro
medio de este entero aquí tengo otro
medio de este entero y aquí tengo uno
más otro medio de este entero y
seguramente te vas a preguntar por qué
hacen esto porque nos dan esta pista
bueno lo que quiero que veas es
siguiente cada medio es de hecho un
cuarto de estos dos enteros si agarras
estos dos enteros y los divide en cuatro
partes iguales te vas a topar que cada
una de estas partes cada uno de estos es
un cuarto de estos dos enteros dicho
otra manera si me tomo un cuarto de dos
enteros de dos enteros eso es lo mismo
que un medio y aquí lo puedes ver
tenemos dos enteros y al dividirlos en
cuatro partes iguales cada una de estas
secciones es un medio de un entero
completo es la mitad de un entero por lo
tanto un medio es lo mismo que un cuarto
de dos enteros pero nos están
preguntando por cuánto es tres cuartos
de 2
bueno pues tenemos que observar lo
siguiente tres cuartos de dos es lo
mismo que tomarme uno
dios más un medio más un medio y tal vez
esto sea un poco confuso para ti porque
estoy hablando de cuartos y de medios y
de enteros y todo esto pero recuerda lo
siguiente un cuarto de todos es lo mismo
que un medio así que si me tomo tres
cuartos de dos cuánto va a ser eso vamos
a sombrear lo bueno pues éste sería un
cuarto de dos de lujo aquí tendría otro
cuarto de dos de lujo y por último aquí
tendría otro cuarto de dos así que aquí
tengo tres cuartos de dos ahora bien
solamente basta que recuerdes que un
cuarto de dos es lo mismo que un medio
así que aquí tengo un medio más aquí me
voy a tomar dos cuartos de dos entonces
tengo dos medios ya que me voy a tomar
un tercer cuarto de dos lo cual me va a
dar tres
un medio más un medio más un medio son
tres medios y eso es lo mismo que tres
cuartos de dos déjame escribirlo
que es justo lo que tengo aquí coloreado
muy bien así que vamos a quitar este y
vamos a hacer uno más el último es este
de aquí que dice cuánto es cuatro
quintos de diez así que es buen momento
para que de nuevo pausa el vídeo y vea
si lo puedes resolver por tu cuenta muy
bien ahora veamos qué nos dice nuestra
pista observa tenemos una recta numérica
que va de 0 a 10 dividida en cinco
partes iguales entonces cada uno de
estos que tengo aquí cada uno de estos
que tengo aquí es una quinta parte de 10
es más déjeme escribirlo este de aquí
una quinta parte de 10 tenemos de 0 a 10
dividido en cinco partes iguales
entonces esta de aquí es una quinta
parte de 10 y ahora qué número es este
bueno pues si observas este número va a
ser lo mismo que 2 por lo tanto ya puedo
decir que 2 es una quinta parte de 10 es
más déjame escribirlo una quinta parte
de 10 esto es lo mismo que 2 pero ojo no
nos están preguntando por una quinta
parte de 10 lo que nos preguntan son por
cuatro quintas partes de 10 si aquí
tengo un quinto de 10 este aquí es un
quinto de 10 bueno pues aquí ya tengo
dos quintos de 10 aquí tengo tres
quintos de 10 y aquí tengo cuatro
quintos de 10 aquí tengo cuatro quintos
de 10 así que habrá que fijarnos en el
número al que llegamos
este de aquí y vamos a contar lo tengo 0
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 así que el número que
llegamos es 8 así que déjame ponerlo
este de aquí es 8 y ahora si puedo decir
cuánto es cuatro quintos de 10 bueno eso
es lo mismo que el número 8